wait and how is it that everybody found
out about your surrogate by the way this
is the bonus keeping up with the
kardashians clip that has people talking
can't really come on Kim Kardashian
revealing how everyone found out she was
pregnant with baby number four vs
surrogate turns out she was a little
tipsy I got drunk on Christmas Eve and I
told someone at Christmas you know
remember who I told as I was drunk
moldable people I think so are you upset
no I don't drink
Yeah right yeah hilarious this is the
party they're talking about the
star-studded holiday bash Kim through
[Music]
and it would seem Kym and Paris Hilton
were having a great time
and get this
Chloe was definitely getting into the
spirits to know it was the most fun it's
ever been ever know yeah I'd rather
remember I was like I mean how do we get
invited next year how often do you get
to have snow no way that's what I told
Courtney seriously but after the group
recounted the night the convo quickly
turned to Kim's feelings a hon baby
number four can you believe you're gonna
have another kid running around I'm
insane
I'm so excited what first I was having
such an anxiety just because I'm gonna
be the mom of four and leave it to Kris
to really just bring this whole clip
home look at your mom have 19 kids she's
not stressed I want to kill myself goals
amazing of course we now know Kim and
Kanye welcomed baby number four Psalm in
May the inspiration was the Book of
Psalms in the Bible so I think it's just
a wonderful way to celebrate you know
how they feel and he's such a blessing
so it's perfect
alright guys that's it for today for all
the latest on the Kardashians make sure
that you keep it locked to all things et
until next time I'm Katie Krause and bye
for now
[Music]